la russie restreint temporairement le
trafic routier ferroviaire chez thoniers
et maritimes dès ce dimanche soir
c'est ce que précise le décret publié ce
samedi par le gouvernement
objectif prévenir l'entrée sur le
territoire russe de nouvelles infections
au coronavirus fermeture également de la
frontière avec le bélarus habituellement
ouvertes et se traversant sans contrôle
douanier quelques exceptions sont faites
diplomates ou citoyens peuvent quitter
la russie en cas de décès d'un de leurs
proches à l'étranger
les habitants de nationalité russe
vivant à dos niet school ou pense que
près de la frontière ukrainienne ne sont
pas non plus concernés par la mesure
la russie a déjà annoncé jeudi dernier
la suspension de toutes ses liaisons
aériennes sauf pour rapatrier les
citoyens russes bloqués à l'étranger
mi mars et les autorités ont également
fermé les frontières aux citoyens
étrangers à l'exception des résidents
permanents dans le pays puis depuis ce
samedi la russie a décidé de fermer
jusqu'au 5 avril prochain tous les
commerces et restaurants du pays
les magasins alimentaires les pharmacies
ne sont bien sûr pas concernés par cette
restriction aux manettes de ce taux vous
savez que la semaine prochaine a été
déclarée semaines de congés par le
président a cédé garges est-il
nécessaire d'étendre à toutes les
régions de notre pays
les mesures restrictives déjà prise à
moscou et dans la région de moscou
il s'agit tout d'abord du secteur des
loisirs et des divertissements
ces décisions sont évidemment dur et je
voudrais m'adresser à tous les citoyens
de notre pays
prenez au sérieux et agissez de manière
responsable a concédé ce crime ce lieu
où le président vladimir poutine a
également annoncé cette semaine des
mesures de soutien au pouvoir d'achat et
aux entreprises face à la crise
économique provoquée par la pandémie
enfin la lutte contre le coronavirus se
joue dans les laboratoires ce samedi
l'agencé fédérale russe de biomédecine a
présenté un médicament pour le
traitement de kovy
9 un schéma thérapeutique basée sur le
médicament antipaludique méfloquine
d'après le communiqué de fin masashi
tard le